so we both just saw this movie last
night
what was your first thoughts and seeing
it on the screen i
speechless well i i knew what would
happen right i knew what would happen in
the scene so i thought i was prepared
i thought i knew what would happen but
at the moment it came on screen
i was still surprised every moment
surprised me
and in you just see john's perspective
his vision and now to see the monster in
real
you know on the screen it really
terrified me
yeah there must have been some pressure
this being a sequel because the first
one was so
so successful did you have a little bit
of fears going into this one
no no no when john john skyped me and he
talked to me about the idea of his story
we were on the phone for about 45
minutes and
you know before that i i actually before
we had the conversation i thought there
shouldn't be a sequel because
a quiet place i just felt was perfect
but when he brought up his idea and
shared his vision with me i said oh my
god i have to do this i just
there's no way i can't and after the
conversation
you know everything went smoothly and i
was very confident in what we were doing
and the vision we were
making i knew what this world would be
and i thought i understood what the
reaction
from the audiences would be yeah and
this starts literally seconds after the
first one ended
was there concerns with trying to get
back to that emotional intensity of
where the first one left off
um we had the same cast so that helped
right and it was the right
story and it was the right cast so i
think that we could
you know we made the emotional level
possible and we i think we did it
yeah and john says you have the most
intense role
in this sequel i mean your character
really steps up in a big way what did
that feel like to get to play that
it was a shock really i have to say a
surprise and it was
difficult actually her role regan she
has to change because she's not a child
anymore
she's a young she's still young she's on
the cusp
so you have that place of having
needing to have the confidence of an
adult and having the
motivation and the goal to get your
journey to complete your journey
i think it was hard yeah there's been so
much talk in hollywood over the past
couple years about
differently abled actors getting to play
roles or getting the opportunity to play
roles
do you think things are changing a
little bit in hollywood
i hope so i i see it i do see
small changes already i i think but if
we brought in more writers more
producers more directors
and we were involved people from the
disabled community
and i think of the industry we're more
open to new ideas and hearing what
the stories that the community wants to
tell i think the
world would be a better place not just
hollywood yeah well congratulations on
this movie my heart is still racing
thank you so much